♪♪♪♪
-Hey, everybody.
It is time once again
for Corrections,
our online-only
segment of the show
where we talk about the things
we got wrong last week.
We did it for the first time
a week ago,
and this is a bummer --
We made a bunch of mistake
in the corrections.
So, this has instantly becom
like a snake eating its tail
Otherwise known
as an ouroboros?
Let me know.
So, we had "criminy."
I said "cry-miny" in the show.
Shoemaker told me
it was "cry-miny."
Bunch of people said
it's "crimm-iny."
You got it wrong.
So I went out on Corrections
shamed Shoemaker.
And then, like,
tenfold more people
said it was "cry-miny,"
so I owe you an apology.
Not gonna give it to you..
-Aww!
-[ Laughing ]
-Owe it to you.
Also, in our Mary Poppins
sketch this week,
I was wrong when I...
...sang "Chime Chime-iny."
[ Laughter ]
I mentioned the Afghan cit
"Kah-ble."
I called it "Ka-bool,"
but I also said
it was an Afghani city.
That's incorrect.
Afghani is the currency.
I should have said it was
an Afghan city of Kabul.
Also, people told me
both are fine.
[ Laughter ]
I mentioned
the play "Our Town"
and said it was musical.
Lot of people said,
"'Our Town's' not a musical!
So I apologized,
and then, again,
a bunch of other people
were like,
"There was a musical version
of 'Our Town'
called 'Grover's Corner.'"
So, those are three things
I corrected
because people told me
I got it wrong,
and then a bunch of other people
called it right.
But, you know, those commentors?
They won't issue
their corrections.
What else?
I mentioned... [ Laughs ]
I mentioned the
New Zealand Prime Minister
Jacinda "Arden."
This "Jacinda."
[ Laughter ]
I said it wrong.
It's "Ardern,"
and I want to apologize
to the Prime Minister,
especially a prime ministe
who's handled this pandemi
so well, as we know you have
Hey, this one wasn't mine.
In Jokes Seth Can't Tell,
we had a story --
Again, this is
New Zealand-based.
We had a New Zealand story
and then Amber --
Amber's punch line
was, "Crikey."
And then, a lot of
New Zealand people --
-Ha-ha!
-A lot of New Zealand people
said, "That's not New Zealand.
That's Australia."
-Fight me!
Tell them to fight me!
-Well, guess what?
I am apologizing for Amber..
-No!
-...which is nothing new!
-That's no--
-The only nice thing
about this pandemic...
-I take it back!
-..is not having
to go to restaurants
and apologize for Amber...
-No!
-...and the way
she treats the wait staff.
-No, you say "crikey,"
and you know it.
-Are you talking
to people of New Zealand?
-[ Laughing ]
-Oh, my gosh.
Well, guess what?!
New Zealand Peacock
just dropped your show!
-Noooooo!
-Mike Scollins wrote...
[ Laughs ]
Mike Scollins wrote a joke
about how Dick's Sporting Good
has their own line of clothing
which now leads
to a guy saying...
[ Laughs ] They s--
[ Laughing ]
His punch line --
and, again, he puts no thought
into any of this...
[ Laughter ]
...was some version of,
"Well, I'll go
check in the back.
What's your Dick's size?"
I then referenced the fact
that it doesn't make sense
because it's not like
they have different sizes
at different stores.
I was then told by,
I believe,
every woman
who watches our show...
[ Laughter ]
...how wrong I was.
So I'd to apologize for that
Oh, I pronounced...
...the name of the --
I pronounced the "Lord of
the Rings" dragon "Smog."
And it's actually pronounced
"Puff the Magic."
[ Laughter ]
Yesterday's Closer Look,
we had a joke
about porcupines
shooting their quills,
and porcupines
don't shoot their quills.
Somebody told me they don't --
It was once thought
they shot their quills.
Now, it turns out
they just detach easily
when you touch them,
which means -- [ Laughs ]
I don't know how the
"shoot the quills"
theory started.
Some gu-- [ Laughs ]
Some guy came home like...
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
I guess 'cause some guy
came home, like,
covered in quills,
and his wife was like,
"What happened?!"
And he's like,
"I didn't touch it."
She says, "Did you
touch a porcupine?"
He's like, "No!
I was near it,
and it just shot."
She's like, "If I find out
you touched another
(bleep) porcupine --"
And he was like, "I didn't
They shot out!"
And then, that was, I guess,
the consensus for a long tim
until they were like,
"I think he lied to you.
I think he touched a porcupine."
So, there you have it.
Pretty good week overall.
And, again, I want people
to take this seriously.
We just are trying so hard
to be perfect.
[ Laughs ]
But when you correct --
I don't want to hear about
"crimm-iny," "cry-miny" again.
Just let that go.
And if it's an either/or,
let it go.
We don't need to just spend --
Because here's the thing.
[ Voice tightening ]
This is the last thing
I do in the week
before the crew goes home.
[ Laughter ]
So, if it gets self-indulgent...
[ Laughing ]
...it's not worth it.
Will you admit you were wron
on "crikey"?
-Seth, this segment
is not good for you.
-[ Laughs ]
-You have to stop doing this
-I can't hear you
through your mask.
We'll be right back.
We won't. This is just online.
-[ Laughing ]